today is day one of the transition over
the next couple days you'll hear some
more announcements they will primarily
come from Michael because I'm gonna
spend a little time with my kids they
deserve to see their dad a little bit
more than they have the last couple
weeks but we're excited we're excited
about where we're going to take this
state we're excited about having the
first active educator since Martha Layne
Collins I'm also excited to make sure
that we can bring Kentuckians together
then we can be civil to each other again
and that there's so much that we can do
together so I'm happy to take your
questions
well I'm not one of the pundits but
thankfully I'm now the governor elect to
the Commonwealth of Kentucky I believe
that this race is about our families
wanting someone that cares about them
that reflects their values and that is
focused on those issues that they are
anxious about at the end of the day and
those are public education pensions
health care and jobs I'm not worried
about what national pundits or national
Democrats are saying I'm worried about
our families here in Kentucky and making
sure I do a good job for them well
there's about three questions in there
now we're gonna start bringing Kentucky
together by changing the tone no more us
versus them no more this side or that
side this is about focusing on those
core issues public education pensions
health care and jobs that are good for
every single Kentucky family I mean just
imagine having a state where we have
unity of purpose where we can all work
on those areas that are good for every
single family and yes you're gonna see
Republicans in our cabinet
you're gonna see independence in our
cabinet all I'm gonna look for are the
best people who will do the best job
well I don't know what information he's
working off of I know that what about
5,000 votes and terribly close you know
80 something votes was that primary four
years ago we're confident in the outcome
of the election but today is about
moving forward you know the election is
over no one else is going to cast a vote
it ended last night and we're going to
make sure that we make this transition
as smooth as we can because the people
of this Commonwealth have needs and they
need their next governor to be ready and
to be addressing those needs immediately
I'm done with running for office it's
now time to govern i'ma let national
pundits talk about that one too now
there I think what I know is that we saw
our families come out and say they
wanted a governor that is focused on
Kentucky on those core issues of public
education and also of decency and of
living out our values of respecting each
other you know living by that golden
rule where we treat all of our neighbors
with respect and we realize that we are
all each other's neighbors you know even
people of another political party and
even people who disagree with you in
Kentucky we still expect our leaders and
everyone else to be civil with each
other I believe this race was about
those areas where you know in Kentucky
we need to do so much better well I'm
here today to announce the transition
and we can only have a transition
because the election is over but but we
are we are excited to move into this
governance stage because we believe that
we can put together a leadership team
not just for a transition but for a
cabinet that can serve all Kentuckians
and that's eastern western northern and
central Kentucky that we can be a group
that truly governs for all of
families there are now we're gonna move
forward
whatever process that the governor
chooses to go down you know it's not
going to change this overall number of
votes we are going to take the steps to
move forward to make sure that we are
ready now that we are ready on the day
that we're inaugurated that we are ready
for that first session that we are ready
with that first budget and that we are
ready to take those steps that we have
promised in week one that include
rescinding that Medicaid Waiver and
saving health care for ninety five
thousand Kentuckians of giving this
state a brand-new Board of Education and
restoring voting rights for more than a
hundred and forty thousand nonviolent
felons that's what we're going to look
at every option that is out there to
make sure that we can provide affordable
and accessible health care to our people
that is both making sure that we have a
robust expanded Medicaid program but
it's also about reducing the price of
pharmaceuticals I've been aggressive as
Attorney General I'm going to use every
bit of leverage as governor to reduce
prices not just for our state plan and
for Medicaid but for all of our
consumers across Kentucky and we are
gonna focus on insulin as one of our
first steps yes I like the sound of that
there is a presidential election next
year
is there a take away though that you
would like other Democrats across the
country to take away from well I would
hope my take away is for people running
for office either as Democrats
Republicans or independents and that
you're running to serve the people of
your state and so your campaign should
be about the issues that impact your
state what you want to do as governor
for those families you know I love this
Commonwealth I believe that our people
have so much potential and my role as
governor is to help unlock that
potential to help us be the very best
state we can be to create six-figure
jobs across the Commonwealth to make
sure that everybody can take their
parents or their kids to see a doctor
when they're sick to make sure that
everyone lives that life that they
deserve - here in the Commonwealth I
believe that we will absolutely be able
to forge those alliances and it's about
working with people on the issues that
you agree on and and yes you may you may
fight on the issues that you don't but
understanding that there's always that
next issue that's out there that you're
gonna have to come back together and
work on we can disagree without being
disagreeable and part of that is
changing the tone which is what we're
doing here today it's not constantly
going after each other you know the
politics part of this is over you know
it's time for governance and that's a
tone where we respect everyone
regardless of what party they're in
without acknowledging what happened well
I think we're moving on with our
transition today well I've reached out
and left a message with Daniel Cameron
I'm gonna talk to him about that issue
you know he won that election I want to
make sure that I get his thoughts that's
again part of you know changing the tone
where we can all work together and I
want to make sure he has some input in
that well we'll have to look through all
those all those possibilities you know I
haven't had a lot of time since last
night to think about that but Daniel and
I are going to talk about that before I
talk about it publicly yes sir I've been
on a leave leave of absence
during the campaign and so I will
officially end that leave of absence
enjoying obviously the administration
make it official yeah you know it those
kids that we work with every day means
so much to us and being able to have an
impact at the ground level with our
families and our communities means a lot
to me and that's gonna be hard but I do
look forward to the opportunity to be
able to have an impact for all Kentucky
kids across this Commonwealth working
with some pretty great partners sitting
here piloting
you know I think there are a lot of
polls that we're out I'm not sure I saw
that one you know I I don't know what
information other people had on hand but
you know the election ended last night
today we are moving past politics into
governance being focused on public
education pensions health care and jobs
and changing the tone so that we can be
an administration that serves every
family well I again I think that the the
national pundits will talk about that I
just hope it means that every election
that we see in Kentucky focuses on the
critical needs of our families think if
we had an election where the entire time
was a discussion of how we could better
help our families out there I think that
could help Kentucky that could help
politics to listen the closest race I've
run now I believe that that you know
what now that now that the election is
over that it gives me an opportunity to
to prove myself to every single Kentucky
and out there whether they voted for me
or not because regardless of how they
voted I'm gonna serve as their governor
and regardless of how they voted I'm
gonna try to be a good governor for them
you know I've known a few governors I
didn't just want to be one
I want to govern well and I believe
governing well is governing for every
single family and if anyone still has
lingering feelings from last night I'd
say just wait and watch how we do watch
how we approach this watch how we work
really hard every single day well
there's got to be a swearing-in in early
December but this is this this race this
outcome isn't going to change it's over
what now we are moving forward to make
sure that we have that type of smooth
transition to where we can serve our
people that very next day and and I
believe that Governor Bevin after
deciding whatever his options are or
what he's going to do will help in that
transition and we have seen it from
governors of all different parties and I
believe that that he's going to do the
right thing and make sure that we are
ready to go on day one I've left a
number of messages especially for those
that are in leadership I've also called
and left messages to congratulate each
of the winners on the down ticket I've
received a couple messages back from
Mike Harmon and and Michael Adams all
right thank you